since i've done a prank oh my god i'm
scared
what would make him really mad let's
think that he's going to be like what
the [ __ ]
all right we got a special guest in
studio
the one and only gigi gorgeous hey hey
you know what i'd want to do and this is
a bad segue
to a prank i like doing pranks i like
doing like
uh like phone calls and that and
since i've done a prank i'm like really
itching yes this is fun
and we were talking before because i
thought you know it'd be fun you
probably know a lot of people and you're
probably connected to a lot of people
it'd be fun to prank somebody you know
so we pranked august since we were just
talking about him what could he like he
wouldn't
okay so you're he's expecting you uh
this afternoon for a fitting
he no his team is he's in miami and i'm
the guy
i forgot that i already set this up a
little bit we talked about this
yeah and then i said oh my god i'm going
on howie mandel's podcast and he wants
me to bring the vma dress
i think i think we should go with you
try the dress on
and then we're live recording so like i
didn't want to say anything and be rude
but you took scissors to it and thought
it would be funny
to cut it up okay yeah and i just didn't
say anything but i like want to let him
know
all right and i'll be putting in the
bathroom right now i'm about to cry okay
should i just say oh my god i'm gagging
call me oh my god i'm gagging
calming if my wife sent me
that's not nat you're saying that to
august august oh my god i'm scared